and to continue on that they're just not
going to pinch their d as much and try
to back them out and not let too many odd
man rushes happen because so many goals get
scored they used to give up so many odd
man rushes drenan with a backhand shot a
good save by Johansson Edmond picks it up
as the Brads chain Here Comes point if he
pass the stamp goes right back to point to
heaven at the left Point onetime [Applause]
C the first goal of the NHL season Nikita
[Applause] curo coaches always talk about Zone
entries and this one's executed to Perfection
great keeping going now they get to the
step almost like a power play Bang kerov
what a play that's outstanding vision and great
Puck movement here by the lightning C it's coov
doing a great job finding that ice for himself
instead of driving to the net he stops up pops
out gets away from his check opens up for the
onetime when he hits it from there on the CER
off goal to make it one nothing Tampa Bay see
how nashille responds now if can't get it out
off the leg stays in the zone couple of fourth
lines out there now turn shot saved by Soros
three in front oh J and a great opportunity Stam
Co can't quite get enough on that one his point
caused to turn over just lost his top line
is buzzing watch out Point fake shot save by
Soros comes around the r she's got some room chip
it up to Jano Here Comes Jano
now looking fires it oh H the
crossbar now this is the time for Tampa has got
to go up two nothing it's only one nothing they
dominated that first period but Nashville still
this game didn't get going so if you're Tampa you
want to capitalize on this power play s is back
to Heaven here's Stam coach to of the circle BR
shot blocked perier got a piece of that one Nifty
play by stamp Coast to get it to point d off is
open here he is shot stick save by Soros and into
the netti new of course Barry trots returning to
Nashville here come the lightning with numbers
points stops cross two draw B and the leg save
by S not much of an angle for coov still trying
to accumulate those great a chances against the
unproven goalie yonas Johansson that angle shot
rebound save by Johansson bounces to Yosi Barry
to forsburg for O'Reilly down low Nifty pass in
front Save By Glass rebound save by yanson he
robs Roman Yosi to a heavy workload Johansson
just 28 career starts this is start number 29
played for Buffalo Avalanche cup of coffee with
the Panthers Here Comes forsburg now as a man in
front forb Ryan O'Reilly's first as a predator has
tied the game late in the second [Music] period
it's a new acquisition the factor Ryan O'Reilly
this starts all the way from there's Z they go
the entire length of the ice what a play by
Philip forberg and he puts it on the guitar
strings for Ryan O'Reilly and boy oh boy is that
sweet music Callie oh yeah is what a tow drag by
forsberg on that one O'Reilly knows it too gives
him the point game number 769 in his NHL career
for Tyson Barrett 32-year-old oneyear deal 4.5
million left sergachev off the side of the post in
this game serf flat footed watch out for trening
works his way around him drops it back shot save
by Johansen is PA Smith teed that one up high and
Let It Fly those are our two goal scores Nikita
COV and Ryan O'Reilly it's a 1-1 game after 40
see who makes the first move here in the third
it's been all Nashville forsburg in front score
yo Parson in gives Nashville a 2-1 lead 11 seconds
into the third period second intermission it's
paid volumes here quickly right off the face off
to start the third frame and cev just moves his
footing great Pursuit and the for check little
punt recovery by Ryan O'Reilly and a quick lateral
Play Beautiful goal by Parson they'll try to ride
their Elite goenda at the other end and bring this
puppy home let's see how Tampa Bay response a in
front forsberg save Johansson still loose whacking
at it Johansson trying to cover and he finally
does Paul chips it over to stamp Coast first
time stammer has been able to T one up in this
game here comes Hond walking in back to COV
point shot deflected wide great stick in front
back to COV he's already scored tonight stamp
Coast in front Paul looking for the to in scar
[Applause] [Music]
Tampa absolutely buzzing great recovery to C's
point and now they go cross scene and it's right
in front of the net second third effort and it's
in the nick of time because it's Nick fall out of
Miss Saga that puts it home see what you did there
weekie new addition into the power play Nick Paul
big body in front of the net Brandon Hegel
one-onone for the lead in [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] Tampa Qui penalty shot goal to take
the lead oh and G Hegel unreal Patience by Hegel
the decep I on the release right here leg over
the fire hydrant it's a power play league right
now forsberg now has been a great playmaker
walks in looking backand a save by Johansson
and myy save thomasino now has it he's one these
young Predators get a big goal here and tie the
game midway to the third Novak SC holy sniky
a twisted rer from Tommy Novak 35 points in
his final 36 games last year he has tied the
game here on this one Tommy Novak with laser
guided accuracy to the short side and I want
you to watch him come downhill absolute laser
Cali what a shot incredible placement absolutely
realizes the Han playing back a little bit there
C dammer save Soros Yosi can't get it by stamp
Coast Paul retrieves it to Cerro going to walk
in back hand pass Point serf shot save score
Nick Paul Tampa Bay leads [Music] [Applause]
again after going through St Co for about
three attempts it's a recovery on the left
boards into in the middle of the screen but
keep your eye on the big man number 20 Nick
Paul playing the role of power forward in
tight and he makes no mistake here yeah C
J's going to shoot this going to go off Paul
looks like off Soros back on to Paul's stick
for his Tyson Barry behind the net less than
15 seconds to go Yosi they need a shot there
it is tip rebound back hand blocked
CER off he's going to ice this one up
100% value effort by the PRS give them their
credit Mita CRA makes himself available in the
beone he got blown The Zone there I love his
discipline in the defensive Zone made himself
an outlet and ever so smoothly goes the leg to
the ring and puts it home Kelly that's start
with the save from Johansson he gets the win
for the Tampa Bay Lightning we got to go boys